welcome to hannity we begin a fox news
alert if you missed at an amazing town
hall in pennsylvania earlier tonight
right here on the fox news channel we
have the highlights
also breaking tonight we're about to
reveal some disturbing
frankly repugnant newly unearthed audio
from quid pro quo joe
on african americans on women it's when
i was a young senator that is moments
away tonight plus
numbers do not lie president trump's
massive huge
record turnout on super tuesday set new
records broke all expectations
now remember the republican primary is
not contested
pretty amazing numbers that you won't
get from the mob
now also coming up we'll analyze that
karl rove has his whiteboard will also
have the very latest
fallout from capitol hill where yep
chuck schumer that guy
is in big trouble tonight over the
threat of violence directed at two u.s
supreme court justices
now his appalling behavior might
actually land him in serious legal
jeopardy we'll explain that's straight
ahead
first we start with something you will
never see in the media mob that are
abusively biased towards the president
we're actually going to vet quid pro
quojo now this is only the beginning of
what will be a long process
because in the next 243 days well you
will be the ultimate jury and we want
you to be as informed as possible
remember they never vetted obama we did
the mob will circle the wagons around
the chosen one
they will act like his gaffes mean
nothing oh it's not a big deal they'll
ignore it
they might also ignore his record which
is atrocious
and many other things we will cover it
all on this show
anything and everything in their power
they will do to protect joe biden
from and shield them from any negative
coverage so it's up to us that's our
job and thank you for giving us this
camera every night to help inform the
american people on serious problems
surrounding yes former vice president
quid pro quo
joe currently we have identified three
issues that should concern every
american voter one
it is the legitimate question over
whether or not the 77 year old biden has
the stamina
and the strength the mental acumen and
focus required
to serve in what is the most difficult
job
in the world period now we've covered
this issue in depth last night
without a doubt biden is struggling if
he had a fastball
it's gone if he had a slow pitch that's
gone too and it's confusing
and bumbling speeches increasing numbers
of gas
public outbursts are beyond troublesome
most people see it the media mob's
trying to ignore it now the issue number
two surrounds quid pro quo joe
and the issue of corruption there are
now multiple
ongoing independent investigations in
the u.s senate
ron johnson from wisconsin leading the
way there and in the country of ukraine
involving biden's shady activity in
ukraine
you're not getting the billion until you
fire the prosecutor investigating my
zero experience son paid millions that
doesn't go away because they want it to
go away
of course we'll continue to track this
ongoing scandal because a big
investigation is also going on in
ukraine
we will follow it wherever the truth
leads to also tonight we'll focus on
biden's third
major issue he has a track record by the
way
i would say 78 year old bernie he has
the energy and stamina
a lot more than joe biden but the 77
year old career politician
first elected to the u.s senate in 1972
has a long dicey public history
which brings us to our shocking new
audio this was may 18
1973. try and listen to this through the
prism of
what if donald trump said it then
senator biden gave a lengthy speech to
the city club of cleveland we have
confirmed with them that in fact these
are his remarks
it was also covered by cleveland.com and
breitbart and other news sources
he bragged the politicians were more
moral more moral
than doctors that save our lives lawyers
and even
indian chiefs can't make this up take a
listen
politics should be the most honorable of
professions
those of you who are doctors and lawyers
and indian chiefs in the audience
how can any of you possibly do as much
good
if you're very good at what you do as i
can do if i'm very good at what i can do
uh that's pretty arrogant i don't think
they do more damage than in the swamp
biden went on to clarify however he
wasn't particularly moral
a moral person himself interesting
admission listen to this
i fortunately had over three thousand
individual contributors
nobody makes up any more than one
percentage point of my total budget
nobody for one percentage points gets
ahold of that ear
nobody gets any more than a return phone
call for that
one percent but it's not because i'm
particularly moral
it's because nobody took me seriously
by admitting he'll pretty much do
anything to maintain power
wow but the most shocking parts of the
audio involved involves statements about
women and minorities in fact he made
several derogatory jokes
about women in the audience they didn't
even think they were oh they told me you
weren't going to be here oh i
i wasn't expecting you to be here take a
listen
only analogy i can really think of is
a football analogy and i apologize to
you women in the audience for not being
able to think of a more appropriate
analogy but they told me here they
didn't want you here anyway i didn't
expect any women to be here
i didn't want women here anyway i was
going to speak to a group of guys what's
that
i came here to talk football you can't
possibly know anything about football
you imagine if any republicans said this
the hysteria and the media mob
it would be non-stop the coverage would
be apoplectic
outrage moral selective outrage as it
usually is
there's one more one point in the speech
biden singled out a woman
in the front row asking a question
listen to this
senator i find you very articulate may i
ask
the
masks
the rest is not very good that's what i
thought
that's why
that's why i tried to compliment it but
i scare you out of it
to the best of your knowledge senator do
you believe that the democratic party
has ever been
involved in something as atrocious as
bugging
sure yes yes i do but bugging isn't the
question kiddo
yeah kiddo okay oh
they didn't want you here anyway this
guy is trying to win over what social
justice warriors in the democratic party
and there's more at one point than
senator biden actually refers to
african americans but all i see is a
horrible
degrading word listen for yourself
i think the two-party system although my
democratic colleagues don't like me
saying this i think the two-party system
is good for the south and good for the
good for the black in the south
now that's the current front runner of
the democratic party we reached out to
biden and the biden campaign for comment
they have yet responded now remember
according to their rules you must be
held accountable for every single word
you've ever said
and anything you've ever done that is
unless of course you're a democrat and
you believe with them
now you might want to also remember joe
biden
well even in this speech he praised the
known segregationist
and get this cleveland.com first
reported these disturbing remarks in may
of 2019 and i doubt any of you saw this
up until now and nearly everyone in the
media mob
they ignored it of course they did biden
meanwhile has a long record of weird
offensive and frankly racial rhetoric
what you just heard is nothing new take
a listen
the largest growth in population is
indian americans
moving from india you cannot go to a
7-11 are a dunkin donuts unless you have
a slight indian accent
what kind of a chance with a
northeastern liberal like joe biden
stand
in the south better than anybody else
and you don't know my state
my state was a slave state my state is a
border state my state is the eighth
largest black population in the country
you got the first
sort of mainstream african american
who is articulate and bright and
clean and a nice looking guy i mean this
that's a storybook
they're going to put you all back in
chains first time ever i'm bright and
and articulate and clean
african-american this is a storybook
what you heard that right biden once
referred to obama
as the first mainstream african-american
who's
articulate bright and clean why is the
radical extreme socialist democratic
party
lining up behind a very flawed candidate
who also praised segregationists
apparently they now have no choice
elizabeth warren is officially out
no one liked her and the other candidate
just spent
weeks doubling down on his praise of
murdering communist dictatorships
moments ago during a fox town hall
president trump he was on his a-game
tonight offered his own analysis of the
democratic race take a look
so you want to face joe biden or bernie
sanders that's my question i'll tell you
i was all set for bernie because i
thought it was going to happen
you know we get ready for things right
so mentally i'm all set for bernie
communist i had everything danny that
i was all set and then we have this
crazy thing that happened right on
tuesday which he thought was thursday
but he also said 150 million people were
killed with guns and he was running for
the united states senate
support me i'm running for the united
states there's something going on there
i was all set i was all set for bernie i
was ready to go and then i said you know
i don't think i'm running against
bernie i think it's going to be very
hard for him to come back
all right now if you're a joe biden
supporter and you don't have a fastball
if you ever had one or you don't have a
slow pitch and
you watched president trump uh who are
you going to bet on in those debates
president is spot on but really the
socialists well i guess
they should be happy either way because
here is the point that i made
about super tuesday no one else in the
media made in the lead
up to super tuesday bernie sanders
sanders was doubling down on defending
murdering dictators and their regimes
the castro's
former soviet union ussr oh
danielle ortega venezuela well okay
even democrats think that we we can't
defend murdering dictatorships
so but the differences between bernie
and biden
they're few and far between and we've
got the tape they both support the new
green deal they both support
open borders they both support free
health care for illegal immigrants they
both openly vowed to raise your taxes
they both want to take away your second
amendment rights and the list goes on
and they have extreme positions on
abortion
in fact in 2016 then vice president
biden he
showered bernie sanders with praise
said oh i just wish he didn't call
himself a socialist because everything
else is great
he all but endorsed bolshevik bernie in
2016 against hillary
here's the video if bernie sanders never
said he was a democratic socialist
based on what he's saying people
wouldn't be calling him a democratic
socialist
that's how he characterizes himself in
sort of european terms the democratic
socialist
parties in europe but why is she having
trouble
well i i think that that bernie
is speaking to a yearning
that is deep and real
and he has credibility on it oh
deep and real yearning to be what
cuba 243 days ask yourself are you
better off now than you were four years
ago
was the obama biden track record oh the
iranian deal
13 million more americans food stamps 8
million more poverty
lowest labor participation rate since
the 70s i think that was a glowing
success
did you did they fulfill their promise
did you keep your doctor
did you keep your plan because millions
lost them how did that iran deal go
how much money did americans save on
health care yet they didn't really save
a lot on average we're paying 200
percent more for health care across the
country
in quid pro quo joe's five decades in
elected office
did the federal government approve or
worsen
now in 243 days this is the biggest
choice election in our lifetime that's
just the fact the good news tonight is
this
the sheer enthusiasm for president trump
this is the untold story of tuesday
super tuesday president trump
drove a record number of voters to the
polls
in contests that weren't contested
look at this in texas he got more votes
than biden
bernie and warren combined it was an
uncontested election
the media reporting that he received
more votes in vermont minnesota
massachusetts tennessee than any
incumbent in the last four decades
colorado turnout was greater than the
past
three republican primaries combined wow
the media mob they can try and sweep
that under the rug numbers don't lie